did you know that in Attack on Titan the
original user of the cart's item was a
middle-aged man called Oliver Peak
Oliver was introduced in chapter 75 of
the manga where we can see his car
Titans standing next to Zeke looking
drastically different from the version
that later appeared in the anime what
happened is that before the Mali Arc
began isiyama changed his mind and
decided to make the car Titan a young
person who would have more in common
with the other Warrior candidates the
way I see it this was a smart decision
because if the car Titan had remained as
you know this middle-aged guy who was
significantly older than everyone else
then you'd have to question why Mali
trusted a group of 12 year olds to
attack the island rather than swapping
out at least one of them for the more
experienced Soldier